freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
ihr seht schon das ist nicht mein
gewohntes umfeld ich bin heute bei felix
zum frühstück gibt's pancakes ich fange
direkt an also felix herzlich willkommen
natürlich kannst du auf meinem kanal ich
habe nochmal nachgeschaut und warten
nämlich damals in irgendein minecraft
ohne dass ich hier so gehen
und heute hast du die große freude dass
der sagt das ist wirklich coppel verwies
das nicht ausgesucht ich dachte mir wir
machen s bahn mitteilt die so schön dick
werden weil das den bedarf die besten
keinen text ich fang direkt an und du
kannst gerne die seele baumeln lassen
ich seit monaten darauf seit dem
desaster erlebt freilich nicht vor
das sind gute voraussetzungen leute in
weiser voraussicht ich möchte mich nicht
unterstellen dass es nicht hat aber
manche hatten es schon nicht eine vage
mitgebracht damit liegen wir jetzt
erstmals 50 gramm butter 53 aber bei
betis nicht mal ein bisschen mehr
tiroler wäre stolz auf mich okay die
fungiert zum schmelzen in die mikrowelle
dann nehmen wir unsere schüssel mit dem
herz aber auch mitgebracht
dann geben wir 250 km wenn die bürger
geschmolzen ist dass er sie kurz
abkühlen dann 50 gramm zucker drei
teelöffel backpulver oder war sie eine
ganze tüte
gehört das ist keine schlechte kirche
pass wird gewinnen also respekt als viel
drin bin gespannt was sie nicht schon
gut auch ein bisschen salz und zwei
teelöffel vanillezucker sogar schnee
die zutaten vermengen wird so und zu
unserer trockenen mischung geben jetzt
500 milliliter buttermilch und die
mittlerweile kalte butter
das kann zu verrühren wert es hat schon
eine mega neiße konstanz wir wollen das
nicht über mixen sondern nur so ein
bisschen das soll seine struktur auf
jeden fall behalten
zu dem ganzen gehen jetzt zwei große
eier die arbeiten wir auch ein und wir
haben den traum eines pancake teil wird
die fan hat mir gute hitze ein bisschen
drunter
ich mache mal den text test
[Musik]
du hast einen wert und andy hoffe es ist
so süß wie gewünscht hast du ganz
schnell bei der bewässerung schritt ist
ich glaube das ist ein fast schon
unendliche portionen zieht aus dem
amerikanischen teil eine portion das
hängt jetzt anzeigen solcher ist die
muss ehrlich sein
wir sehen uns dass ich ganz geschafft
sein bestes gegeben aber das war ein
verdammt so gut pen täglich muss vom 10
bis 10 ganz genau ich geb den pancakes
eine 9
sie waren sehr sehr lebendig mit die
besten texte hatte mit dem übrigens auch
geil aber ich würde noch empfehlen ich
finds halt mit heiß immer noch so ein
bisschen was weißt du dass du noch etwas
ist entweder was sehr fruchtig ist was
für den future aspekt und filmmaterial
hat hast du mich dieses frische und
flüssen okay da ja ja das stimmt das
wäre eine ergänzung gewesen man muss
hier immer noch steigern könnt aber die
pancakes an sich war mehrere solche
flüssig 19
okay leute das auf jeden fall ein sehr
solider start mit dem tag ich würde
sagen sie uns beim mittagessen das wird
ein bisschen extras wird und erste
süßkartoffeln die süßkartoffel kurier
heute
felix hat sich nämlich von mir ein
chateaubriand hatte auch keine ahnung
was das ist
das gab es nämlich nicht wann mein
manager des vertrauens dementsprechend
habe ich mir gedacht muss es dann aber
auch fans die sein was ich mache ich
habe mich nicht lumpen lassen
ich habe keine hilfe geholt ich habe ja
auch hier auf dem kanal mal ein video
gemacht indem ich vakuums gegrillt habe
aber da hat ihm ein richtig kleines
steak hüfte ist auch das ist nicht ganz
die größe regierung stufe und so
dementsprechend rasch noch bezahlbar
denn die süßkartoffel in würfel
schneiden wir noch zwei proben aus zehn
vereinen würfeln wird pariert
dementsprechend packe ich das jetzt
einfach ein bisschen so nämlich ganz
zwei zwiebeln in die pfanne geben wir so
lieben gerät dann kommen zwiebeln und
knoblauch deshalb nur ein bisschen
glasiert und dann gehen wir auch schon
die süßkartoffel natur
dazu gehen jetzt ein wenig gemüse
berührt und so wird das ganze grab
setzen wir eine weitere fahren und einen
weiteren top braucht eine beschichtete
pfanne zum allerersten von mandeln und
alles auf höchste zeit das fleisch aus
dem kühlschrank zu holen
das hier ist die luft und diesmal sind
sie nicht vergangen ist nicht
versprechen dass ich noch kurz ruhen ich
salz und pfeffer jetzt mal die sich so
wie schneiden ist dass viele entlang der
parser in 3 cm dicke besprachen jetzt
ein bisschen und ich gebe jetzt ein
problem
ich reiste jetzt mal ein mann hält an
wir geben die süßkartoffeln in eine
schale zu einem fahrrad was man will
damit wir die auch zum püree nochmal
aufgreifen und für die cremigkeit guten
leute cream cheese inspirieren wir viele
leute gelegen dass ich auch so ganz
wichtig man muss das jetzt vorher saßen
weil es mag ich mache es immer vorher ja
ich war immer vorher sein und ich werde
von der sagen ja manchmal selbst nicht
weil twitter wird aber ich fühle dass
bitte und ich finds immer gut ja das
stimmt also generell es auf fast 300
grad
zwei minuten
zwei minuten vor seit ungefähr dann
wenden wir das gute stück macht so leute
gelegen hat jetzt in die indirekte zone
[Musik]
sie sehen die ärzte ein bisschen runter
jetzt warten wir fünf minuten so dass
süss kartoffelpüree probiere ich hier
noch ein kleines nest hochschule zu
machen
sehr schön war oder wie gemalt ist sehr
willig sein dass dir schmecken da
endlich welche durch eine ausgezeichnete
auswahl die du getroffen hast hier dank
der gast alles gemacht das klappt nicht
gefragt was sie essen möchte nicht dass
ich so groß so vorschläge so aber dass
dort immer exakt gemacht was ich habe
jetzt das inkl das ist getüftelt regel
sehr gut dadurch eine ordentliche kriegt
halt wirklich durch dieses hohe
temperatur im kontakt mit der großen
platte so könnt ihr auch richtig viele
leute
wir essen auf und dann sehen jetzt
vielleicht zur bewertung so felix der
teller kommt nix mehr da noch einen
letzten mandl rissen das zusammen
geschoss war richtig gut war wehrte und
zeit für die beratung das fleisch und
regelt nicht gut süßkartoffel auch wilma
buch sagen das war so das war so richtig
weiß richtig gut ich habe mit mir selbst
ob ich die zähne raus rücken kann gibt
menschen die können es gibt menschen die
können es nicht und du hast alles hier
so einfach gemacht also das ist einfach
es sieht so aus liebessong weiß man
bekommt das sohn denkt so ist wie aus
einem richtig teuren edel restaurant was
ihr getan hast du musst einfach nur
selbst gemacht ist wirklich die 10
sie war schon nach wie vor alle zähne
damit hätte ich nicht unbedingt richtig
glaubt felix ist schon auch kritisch mit
zehn zum mittagessen leute habe wenn ich
mal beim abends erst einmal besonders
viel mühe geben wir sehen uns da kommen
wir zum abendessen es gibt ab das heißt
es gibt für mich jede menge zu tun ich
fang direkt an und zwar allein feta käse
vor den ich mit thymian kirschtomaten
und beim servieren
super einfach so dass kleine schale so
ausrasten käsereien dann gebt mir dazu
einfach 12 primera nestchen dass toni
automaten so dann packt man das ganze
ein
und so kommen sie einfach später auf den
grill das bringe zum kochen
dann nehmen wir 500 gramm kartoffeln
schälen vierteln die katalanen die
größeren sechstel mehr
manche noch zwei rosmarin ärmchen
rosmarin hatten wir außerdem machen wir
alle bondi gas also hackfleischbällchen
dafür machen wir zehn gramm pinienkerne
klein so die sind fein gehackt
die schlüssel dazu auf keine kuhhaut her
ein 1 2 esslöffel paniermehl eine
esslöffel petersilie es gab leider nur
gefrorene dazu 205 statt fleisch pfeffer
und salz das ganze planeten jetzt sobald
es fertig ist es ungefähr zum ersten
vorne ausbildungs große ehre ist ein
teelöffel backpulver das wasser geben
jetzt kommen die kartoffeln rein
ich nehme jetzt in beide von olivenöl
und der unbeschichteten pfanne rösten
wir rosmarin gemeinsam mit 3
knoblauchzehen nämlich schon bei den
kartoffeln
die kamera ist gut ausgegangen ist weiß
nicht wer es noch mal drauf weiter
möchte dialog angeboten jetzt wirklich
eines triple jetzt schild mir
zwischendurch schnell verdoppeln
die kartoffeln lassen wir kurz nach
einlieferung wir schnell noch eine
knoblauchzehe in feine scheiben so dass
ganze geben wird in das feld in dem ein
bodyguard eingebracht
johnstons heran wir nehmen jetzt einfach
die schüssel geben die kartoffeln rein
nach dem knoblauch rosmarin einfach
normales und ihr fehlten einfach mit
knoblauch pulver das probieren wir es so
ein bisschen aufzubauen ihr kennt sie
mittlerweile zumindest kommen die
kartoffeln aus backblech und auch offen
zu bis sie goldbraun gefühl dass die
küche aus wie ein schlachtfeld sie ist
es auch zu diesem zeitpunkt wir gehen
jetzt in die soße für den geschmack
einen premieren zwei fischen wir später
wieder raus zu betreuen die mit einem
teelöffel zucker nur einmal umrühren
jetzt geht er eine dose gehackten
tomaten dazu leitet das ganze aufkochen
die nazis und väter
und ein wenig
das lassen wir weiterkommen in der
zwischenzeit machen wir juni 250
milliliter ziemlich viele juni können
die mir die restlichen zutaten hier rein
das sei ein esslöffel essig ein
teelöffel zucker eine knoblauchzehe und
klose bauen wir einen teelöffel sind ein
halber teelöffel salz so dass verrühren
wird gehen langsam
der stamm knoblauch ich hin wir geben
jetzt die alcasynn die tomatensoße darin
darin garen die jetzt fertig und wir
geben noch ein bisschen vorsichtig chili
drüber das ist nämlich gerne felix
schafft ist sourcing mit blüten ist wir
sind später absehen deinem leben
immerhin das jetzt mein platz habe
immerhin erwartet auch immer konzept das
über den ich habe eine mission legende
über dich gehört
ich dachte mir vielleicht brauchst du da
martina glas lasse boesen hey du bist
ein held das ist auch so eine geschichte
[Musik]
also ich liebe sowieso trinkt aber auch
jede marke coca cola alles findet auch
folge immer so neue kleine ausprobieren
aber sind auch sehr viel wasserpegel was
aus den anfängen wir können jetzt nicht
sagen dass du alles keine fünf kopierte
wenn wir ihnen sachen jedoch selbst
gemacht habe
das ist übrigens sind alles bis auf der
humus und in salami krebs
hauptberuflichen zutaten beide aber wie
ein räudiger profiwissen stört also
schon als mit dem thema wasser erklärte
video vor interessant das ist sozusagen
die wo die herkommen ganz toll deshalb
gibt es klappt nicht alles vollständig
des papas weil es lange zeit lang
verboten war einfach nur zu trinken in
spanien und deshalb haben diese kleinen
rechte eingeführt man irgendwie immer so
carolin also was zu sagen wir snacken
konnte
damit ist egal war das für mich eine
entschuldigung noch mehr gutes zu tun
ganz genau
okay wir sehen uns denn alles probiert
und auftritt er ist nur dass wir einen
höllen arbeit er keinen stress gesehen
dank wurde ein gesamtüberblick sehr
gerne
wir sehen uns zur finalen bewerten heute
sieht aus als wäre es kaum weniger aber
wir sind seit ungenügende halbe stunde
am essen ist einfach so viel ich werde
das einfach in den nächsten tagen noch
genüsslich auf was nicht aufhören ich
erst mal den kopf musste ich hoffe es
hat ihm geschmeckt und ich bin sehr
gespannt was sie dazu zu sagen hast
musst mich entscheidend und ich muss mir
die noten vergeben wir können erst mal
sogar gehen was war dein fable von
entlassen hier ja tatsächlich dass man
nichts egal dann das fleisch die alberne
die randständigkeit aber ich habe schon
echt was in meinem leben die kisten boni
hat beim mittagessen bin ich von bike
zwischen 9 und 10 18 gegangen ja jetzt
bin ich zwischen 89 g auf 8 und das ist
okay es gibt eine art das war immer noch
sehr sehr sehr sehr gute tat ja aber es
hat claas das hat das fand ich geil und
das fand ich aber nichts hat mich so
richtig raus geflasht okay jaja das
verstehe ich das ist wahrscheinlich weil
ich 15 sachen auf einmal gemacht
ich würde die familie hätte ich es war
wirklich wieder ein tag der mich
getrennt hat sich auf neue daten gemacht
danken dir für deine kohle ausgefallenen
auftragen natürlich sehr gut danke dass
du den ganzen tag genutzt das hier um
mir so leckere essen zuzubereiten und
natürlich schön
wir haben die knoblauch farben unseres
lebens und die ist offen
nächsten sonntag und 14 uhr wenn die
nächste folge kommt wieder weg machs gut
bis dahin tschüss